and I told one of my friends the other
day that I love them and I don't think
I've ever told them that saying that to
people it matters it matters I just
don't understand how people don't
realize that practical positivity not a
delusion not like you're gonna be the
president United States when the persons
can't not delusion actual practical
positivity is a major factor I will pump
that until I can't breathe ready ready
everyone we're coming in hot right now
three two and one I only need to
introduce who I'm standing next you know
what I'm saying you see the face you
already know the head see it all over
social media garyvee what's up baby
what's good fam hey congratulations
because uh you know I know your I have a
Jets fan and two of your people got the
uh defensive and offensive player of the
year yeah Wilson sauce Gardener sauce
out man we're really excited we got some
youth movement Breece Hall Elijah Tucker
Quinn and Williams is still a baby we
got a lot of young talents
we're limited on time someone just get
right to a couple questions right here
man uh when I talk to you well man last
year 2022 I got to go to the office yes
and then I saw you at vcon yes but one
of the things I know we talked about was
empathy and putting out real emotions
and and incorporating that for 2023 we
also said that uh we should be calling
our friends when you're scrolling
and I've been doing that I've been
incorporating more in my life and I told
one of my friends the other day that I
love them I don't think I've ever told
them that and it really does make a
difference and I told him I was proud of
him like I'm getting Goosebumps because
we need more of that bro we need more of
that I just don't understand how people
don't realize that practical positivity
not delusion not like you're gonna be
the president United States when the
persons can't not delusion but actual
practical positivity is a major factor
and sharing like nice like I I saw the
Goosebumps pop off like telling a friend
that you love like Brandon warnicky is
my family I loved him he's been my best
friend since I was 14. I love him saying
that to people it matters it matters and
and I think we should be giving way more
roses to each other instead of pointing
fingers and trying to tear down each
other and I will I will pump that until
I can't breathe all day all day look uh
be friends and let me show you mine
because I didn't know if we were going
to do anything uh this this weekend I
don't know if you had anything planned
but you were ready uh on the on the on
the pickleball front because I have the
um
there's something broom for Daytona in
March okay that's what I was getting
close do we have anything for that also
V conano uh last year Minneapolis this
one we're moving to Indy we're going to
Lucas Oil Stadium where Peyton Manning
put in work the Jets also had a huge win
in
Louisville so that makes me feel good
I'm excited about it
and it really this last year was about
education of web3 this year's more
business marketing pop culture
Innovation augmented reality uh
artificial intelligence there's a lot
going on in the world and we'll be
talking about all that at vikon you know
I'm a student at ASU I'm going for my
MPA but I know education is not for
everybody I follow everything no
education is for everybody well yeah
School taking on massive debt is not
without knowing why you're doing it is
not forever correct correct correct
um so chat GPT that was really good yeah
yeah Chad GPT I know people are like
freaking out professors are like oh what
do we do but meanwhile you still have to
put the work in and formulate different
things but go ahead meanwhile the
critical thinking to put in the query to
get the output for the artificial
intelligence is the big game correct not
just like we romanticize like writing a
letter is better than writing a text why
yeah yeah why yep yep like if that's the
case don't order food on seamless go
cook it yourself thanks like enough with
this [__] um like because again
we're limited on top I mean I would love
to explain with you but
um let's talk about YouTube shorts I
worked out my Instagram Tick Tock
because you know everyone's here
representing different companies and all
that I'm hit a stalemate I know a lot of
people hit stalemates but YouTube shorts
I know you've been talking about that
lady lately is that like the future like
kind of where the people have moved to
it's not that they move there okay but
to your point people hit stalemates and
there's only two ways you could fix that
go to new places to distribute your
content or push yourself creatively to
make different kinds of content right
that's a big push that my team's doing
right now right Dustin like this morning
I posted I said hey I want to do more
handwritten notes ironic because of what
I just said with a letter with video
overlay yeah and sure enough it's
crushing right now because it's a little
different creatively everyone makes the
same content you get into ruts you got
to mix it up are you gonna do a little
green screen right are you gonna do a
duet are you gonna draw are you gonna be
in front of the camera behind the camera
interview people people aren't mixing it
enough which is why people are hitting
ruts they're hitting ruts not because
they're getting Shadow bam or their
algorithms hurting them they're hitting
ruts because they're creatively
interrupt I gotta stop blaming the
shadow man it's my bad it's my fault
right people want to blame the shadow
man none of y'all are getting Shadow bam
you just yeah
facts facts um real quick positivity I I
guess are just words yes of advice for
you know the crypto winner kind of came
and then I think that's why a lot of
people maybe uh brands are navigating
and not necessarily focusing on the
token so much or the coins or the nfts
even though people that are in it
they're in it still but did it do you
feel like it kind of slowed down a lot
of people just people from yeah in this
face what's next I mean what what's next
is it's going to keep growing but
everybody's discouraged because they
want a quick Buck Right even though I
the one of the people that was in it was
saying 99 are going to zero right I made
those videos right I made those videos
constantly right but people just want
gold people want easy and fast
lazy they want easy and fast which is
why they get [__] and so what about
hard and slow people want easy fast what
about falling in love with hard and slow
yes you'll get to where you want to be
yep some of y'all really love that hard
and slow and hard and slow so let's do
this requests how are you incorporating
everything that you're putting together
Vayner Sports uh Super Bowl weekend what
we move into a bunch of our guys are
here Waste Management about to go see a
bunch of them there's 20 30 of our
athletes here yeah real time together
real relationships all that stuff man
there it is garyvee I can't wait boom
thank you
foreign